The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general,
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I thought I
would, in this last lecture
before the break, speak
about one specific topic.
It's often referred to
as a fast Poisson solver,
so what does Poisson mean?
Poisson means
Laplace's equation.
So, this is the
five-point Laplacian,
which could be some other
discrete Laplace matrix,
but let's take the one we know.
So we're in two dimensions,
and you use Poisson's name,
instead of Laplace's
name, when there's
a non-zero right-hand side.
So otherwise, it's a Laplace
solver, but here Poisson.
OK.
So, remember that
right-hand side comes
from maybe a right-hand side
f of x, y in the differential
equation, but it also comes from
non-zero boundary conditions,
because non-zero boundary
conditions, when the five
points hit a boundary, that
known value was moved over
to the right-hand side
and becomes part of f.
So f comes from the non-zero
boundary conditions, as well as
the non-zero right-hand side.
OK.
Important problems, but special
on a square or a rectangle
or a cube or a box,
so we're speaking
about special geometry.
Today, as we've been doing,
I'll take the case on a square,
and you will see that the
whole idea would not fly,
if we were on an ellipse
or something like that.
But a lot of problems on
rectangular domains do appear
in applications,
or we could use --
I hope you always think now
about possible preconditioners.
Any time you have
something fast,
it's a candidate to
be a preconditioner
for a real problem.
The real problem might
not be on a square,
or the real problem might not
have the constant coefficient
that we have in the Laplacian.
In that case, you're not
solving the exact problem,
but one that could be
reasonably close to it.
OK.
So we've discussed the
solution to this problem,
and actually I
have a little more
to say about the movie
that is now on the website,
because I'm quite
excited about that movie.
I'll come to the
movie in a second.
Let me just say what
today's lecture would be.
The key idea here is that the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of this giant matrix of order
N squared by N squared --
size is N squared by N squared.
The eigenvalues and the
eigenvectors are known.
First of all, they're known.
The eigenvectors are nice
discrete sine functions;
they're sines,
because I'm assuming
they come to zero
at the boundary;
so that's why I have a
sine, rather than a cosine.
First, they're
known, and second, we
can work with them very
quickly, using the FFT.
So the point is that
it's quite exceptional;
in fact, I don't think I
know any comparable example,
in which a linear system is
solved by using the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
Usually eigenvalues
and eigenvectors,
they pay off for
differential equations
that are growing in time.
Then it is worth computing
them, because then you can just
multiply by e to the lambda*t,
and you know what's happening
later.
Eigenvectors, eigenvalues have
other purposes, but very, very
rarely are they used to
solve a linear system.
I mean, it's usually
far more work.
And of course, it would
be incredibly more work
if we had to find the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
but for this problem
we know them.
And it also would be incredibly
more work if the matrix
of eigenvectors,
the basis matrix,
the key matrix that
I'll denote by S --
so the eigenvectors
go in a matrix S;
the eigenvalues go in a
matrix capital lambda;
so we know lambda.
It's going to be a simple
matrix, just diagonal,
got those N numbers -- N
squared numbers, I guess,
because we're of size N squared.
But these eigenvectors we know.
So we know them, and we can
compute quickly with them,
using the FFT, or using,
you might want me to say,
fast sine transform,
discrete sine transform,
rather than Fourier
transform, which
we think of as doing
the complex exponential.
So this is a small special
fast Fourier world.
It's a special
fast Fourier world,
in which the FFT and the
related sine and cosine
give us a quick answer,
faster than elimination,
because you all
know, it's n log n,
if n is the number of
Fourier components,
and that's hard to beat.
Then I'll mention also,
for this same problem,
there is another way in
which it can be simplified.
It's not a Fourier way,
just a direct combining
neighboring equations,
so that'll be number two.
OK, but mostly the lecture
is about number one.
The best example I know
in which you would use
eigenvectors/eigenvalues
to solve
an ordinary linear system,
and I'll say in a word
just how you do it, and then
what these eigenvectors are.
OK.
Pause.
Time out to say something
about the movie.
So that movie that's
now on the website
does sparse elimination, and
the example it takes is K2D,
and you can make it 8
squared by 8 squared,
10 squared by 10 squared,
20 squared by 20 squared,
because it shows the order
that the nodes are eliminated
and the graphs of
non-zeros in the matrix.
It's a bit slow.
If you do 20 by 20, you
have to go away for lunch,
well maybe not lunch, but at
least coffee before it's done,
but when it's done, it
counts the number of --
it shows the non-zeros that
are in the elimination,
in the factor L
from elimination,
and it counts the
number of non-zeros,
and I was just talking to
Persson about also getting it
to count the number
of actual flops.
Well, why am I interested?
I'm interested, because I
don't know what power of N
those numbers are growing with.
I don't know whether the number
of non-zeros -- and I did 10,
20, 30, and it looked not too
far from the power capital N
cubed, but the notes say
for nested dissection,
which would be another
ordering, N squared log N. So,
and of course, what power we
get depends on what algorithm we
use for ordering, so nested
dissection is one ordering,
which hopefully we could
put into another movie.
The movie now has exact
minimum degree, real MMD,
which takes as the
next node the one
with absolutely the minimum
degree, not just close to it.
Anyway, have a
look at that movie,
and if you have
any interest, see
how the count increases
as n increases,
and also you could
change, slightly adapt,
the algorithm that
creates the ordering,
creates the permutation
and see what happens there.
There's a lot to do with that,
and it's a pretty fundamental
problem, actually.
We're talking there about what
MATLAB's backslash operation
will do for this equation.
So MATLAB'S backslash
operation will use elimination;
it won't use fast
Poisson solvers,
but now let me come to
the fast Poisson solver.
OK.
So I guess the main
point is I have
to say what are the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
and how do they get used.
So let me say, how
do they get used.
So how can I use
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
to solve a problem like that.
Let me just call it
K rather than K2D.
So K*U equals F. OK.
By eigenvectors.
OK, there are three steps.
Step one.
Expand the right-hand
side as a combination
of the eigenvectors.
OK.
So expand F, this
right-hand side vector,
as some combination of
the first eigenvector,
maybe I'm going to call it
y_1, second eigenvector,
n-th eigenvector, OK, good.
That means -- what do I mean?
I mean you have to find those
c's, that's the job there.
Find the coefficients.
So that's a job, a numerical --
it's a linear system to solve
and we'll see what
it amounts to.
OK, but suppose
the right-hand side
is a combination of
the eigenvectors,
how can you use that?
Well, step two is
the real quick step.
Divide each c_i by the
eigenvalue lambda_i.
OK, so it's by eigenvector,
so I'm assuming that K*y_i is
lambda_i*y_i and that
we know these guys.
So this is known.
And now the question, I'm just
saying, how do we assume known?
So my question now
is how do we use it?
OK, step one -- the idea is
going to be write everything
in terms of eigenvectors.
Work with the eigenvectors,
because if I've
got eigenvectors,
the step is scalar;
I just divide these
numbers by those numbers,
and then I've got the answer.
And then construct -- the
correct answer will be U will
be c_1 over lambda_1 y_1 and
c_2 over lambda_2 y_2 up to c_n
over lambda_n y_n, a combination
of those same eigenvectors with
the same coefficients,
just divided by lambda.
But this is, of course,
another numerical job;
this is like adding
up a Fourier series;
this is like finding the
Fourier coefficients,
this is like
reconstructing the input.
Only because I've
divided by lambda_i,
I'm getting the
output here is U,
when the input was F.
And do you see that that
is the correct answer?
All I have to do is
check that K*U equals F.
So check that this answer from
step three is the right answer.
OK, so I multiply by K.
When I multiply y_1 by K,
a factor lambda_1 appears, the
eigenvalue; it cancels that;
well that's y divided,
so it would cancel,
and I have c_1*y_1.
When I multiply this by
K, K*y_2 is lambda_2*y_2;
cancel the lambda_2's, and
you're left with c_2*y_2,
and so on.
So, when I multiplied by
K, I got F. That's it.
So that's the whole idea
written out, but now,
what actual computations go
into steps one and three?
Step two is pretty simple.
Well, actually this is
a good way to look it.
I want to write that same
algorithm in matrix language.
OK, so in matrix form.
We have the matrix
of eigenvectors,
and that's what I'm
calling S. And it's
got the eigenvectors y_1,
y_2, y_n in its columns.
And the eigenvalue matrix,
we need a name for that too,
and that we decided
to call lambda,
and that's got the
eigenvalues on its diagonal.
So this is 18.06,
linear algebra.
The matrix of eigenvectors,
if I multiply K by S,
then I'm multiplying K by
all its little eigenvectors,
and K times this
gives me lambda_1*y_1,
K times y_2 gives
me lambda_2*y_2,
K*y_n is lambda_n*y_n, and if
I look to see what this is,
this is the same as y_1 to
y_n multiplied by lambda.
If I just multiply on
the right by lambda,
it will take lambda_1
times the first column,
lambda_2 times the second,
lambda_n times the last,
which is what we want,
so it's S*lambda.
This is all n eigenvalues and
eigenvectors in one matrix
equation, that's all that is.
It's just K*S equal S*lambda_i
just says this for all i
at once, all i at the same time.
OK.
So if I use these
matrices in describing
steps one, two,
three, I'll see what's
happening matrix language.
OK, let me just do that.
Step one: step one
is looking for F
as a combination of
the columns of S.
So step one is just
F equals S times c.
The vector of coefficients
multiplies the columns of S
and adds to give
F. Then step two,
which just divides everything
by -- divides by the lambdas.
Step two just creates
lambda inverse S*c.
So I took what I had
-- let's see, no,
the lambda inverse better
be multiplying the c.
Well, actually I can do it
all in -- well step two,
that's the easiest step,
I should be able to do it.
c is changed to
lambda inverse c,
so that c becomes
lambda inverse c, OK.
And then step three
uses lambda inverse c
to construct U. So step
three is: the answer
U, what do I have here?
I've got a combination
of these vectors,
so they're the columns of S,
and what are they multiplied by?
They're multiplied by
the c's over lambdas,
which is what I have here.
That's S lambda inverse c.
Those are the three steps.
And what's the work involved?
Here, the work is solving a
linear system with the matrix
S. Here, the work is
taking a combination
of the columns of s, doing
a matrix multiplication.
Those two steps are usually
full-scale matrix operations,
and of course, the S --
if I just complete this,
I'll see that I get
the right thing,
that's S lambda inverse
and c is S inverse F.
There's the answer.
U is S lambda inverse -- that's
a lambda inverse there --
S inverse F. That's the correct
answer in matrix language.
Right.
This is K inverse,
that's K inverse.
K is S*lambda S inverse, and
if I take the inverse of that,
I get S lambda inverse S
inverse to multiply F. Well,
I doubt if you're much
impressed by this lower board,
because the upper board was
the same thing written out.
It took some indication of
what the separate pieces were,
but it's pretty clear.
OK, now the million dollar
question is, is it fast?
And the answer is,
almost certainly no.
But for the particular matrix
S, which by good fortune,
S could also stand
for sine, this matrix
of eigenvectors for this
particular problem are sines.
These are the discrete sines,
so this is the discrete sine
transform.
That's we're doing, we're doing
the discrete sine transform,
because those discrete
sine vectors are
the eigenvectors of K. OK, now
let me say what that means.
First I'm thinking of K in 1D.
So this is my 2's and
minus 1's and minus 1's.
Its eigenvectors
are discrete sines,
if I multiply that
by sine k*h -- well,
let me just take the first
one, sine h, sine 2h,
sine n minus 1 h, that will
turn out to be an eigenvector.
So this is K*y, K*y_1,
the first eigenvector.
The eigenvectors are
-- let me draw them.
The eigenvectors for that second
difference matrix K are --
here's the interval, 0 to 1,
I chop it up in steps of h,
and I plot the sine, which
starts at zero and ends
at zero, because those are
the boundary conditions,
and here is sine h, sine 2h,
sine 3h, sine 4h, sine 5h,
so for the five by five case --
maybe I should just be using n
here, or maybe I should
even be using capital N,
so capital N is 5
in this example.
Good.
What's on the other side
of that equals sign?
Some eigenvalue times the
same vector, sine h, sine 2h,
down to sine N*h, and
that eigenvalue -- oh,
let me just write
lambda 1 for it.
We know what it is.
The fact that this is an
eigenvector is just trig;
you know, I multiply minus 1
of that plus 2 of that minus 1
of sine 3h, and I use
a little trig identity.
So minus that, 2 of
that, minus that,
turns out that to be
a multiple of sine 2h.
Well, the 2 sine 2h give us a
2, and then the minus sine h
and the minus sine 3h
combine into sine 2h times,
I think, it's a cosine
of h or something,
it's that eigenvector
that's near zero,
because the cosine
of h is near 1.
Does that look familiar?
That a combination
of sine h and sine 3h
should give us twice sine
2h times some cosine,
yep, Elementary trig identity.
OK, so those are eigenvectors.
That's the first one, the
next one would have h times --
the k-th one would have h times
k instead of just h itself,
it would take jumps
of every k -- sine.
and then a cosine h*k
would show up there,
and this would still
be an eigenvector.
OK.
I'm making a little bit
explicit these vectors,
but the main point
is they're sines,
they're discrete sines
at equally spaced points.
That's what the real version
of the FFT just lives on.
And it would also live
on discrete cosines;
if we had different
boundary conditions,
we could do those, too.
So this isn't the only -- these
zero boundary conditions are
associated with the
name of Dirichlet,
where zero slopes are associated
with the name of Neumann,
and both -- this one gives
sines, Neumann gives cosines,
the FFT deals with both.
OK.
So, that's the fast solution,
and it would take N squared --
well I have to go to 2D.
sorry, I guess I
have a little more
to say because I have to get
from this one-dimensional
second difference to the
five-point two-dimensional
second difference,
and that's what's
going to happen over here.
I wrote up some stuff about
the Kronecker operation, which
is the nifty way for
these special problems
to go from 1D to 2D.
You remember the deal,
that K2D, our 2D matrix,
was this Kronecker product
of K and I, that gave us
second differences
in one direction,
and then we have to add in the
Kronecker product of I and K
to get second differences
in the other direction.
And then we better print --
because that matrix is going
to be large, I don't
want to print it.
Yeah.
What's the point?
The point is that if I
know the eigenvectors of k,
then I can find the -- if
I know the 1D eigenvectors,
I can find the 2D eigenvectors,
and you don't have to know
Kronecker products to do that.
All you have to do is just
make a sensible guess,
so the eigenvectors in 2D, are
-- so they have a double index,
k and l, and their components
are sines in one direction
times sines in the
other direction.
So what are those sines?
There's a k*h, I guess, l*h.
Those are the first components,
I guess I have to tell you what
all the components are: k --
the seventh component in the x
direction, there'd be a factor
7 -- so k*m*h sine l*n*h.
This is the (m, n)
component of y_(k, l).
It's just what we had in 1D.
In 1D there was no l, the
components were just sine
k*m*h.
Now we've got two, one
in the x direction --
These are the analogs of the
-- the continuous case would be
sine k*pi*x times sine l*pi*y.
Those are the eigenvectors
as eigenfunctions,
functions of x and y.
And the point is
that, once again,
with these beautiful
matrices, I can
sample these at the
equally spaced points,
and I get discrete
sines that the FFT is
ready to go with, OK.
I'm giving this much detail
partly because the continuous
case, of course, our operators
d second by the dx squared and d
second by dy squared, and
the whole idea of separating
variables, of looking
for solutions u --
here is the eigenvalue problem,
the continuous eigenvalue
problem.
The Laplacian of u,
maybe I do a minus,
the Laplacian of
u equal lambda*u,
and that's a partial
differential equation,
usually it's not easy to
solve, but if I'm on a square,
and I have zero
boundary conditions,
then I've solved it, by
separation of variables,
a function of x times
a function of y.
And that function of
x times function of y
is exactly what
Kronecker product
is doing for matrices, yep.
I thought maybe this is good to
know when the problem is easy,
and as I say, the possibility of
using the easy case on a square
for preconditioning a not
so easy case is attractive.
All right, so
that's what I wanted
to say about number one,
that's the main suggestion,
and again, the point was just to
take these three simple steps,
provided we know and
like the eigenvectors.
Here we know them and
we like them very much,
because they're
those discrete sines.
OK, now just to
finish comes, what's
up with odd-even reduction.
I'll use the same
1D problem first.
It works great in --
that's not good English,
but it works very well in
1D, odd-even reduction,
you'll see it, you'll
see, oh boy, simple idea.
But of course, don't forget
that ordinary elimination
is a breeze with a tri-diagonal
matrix, so nothing I could do
could be faster than that.
But let's see what you can do.
I just want to write
down the -- OK,
keep your eye on this matrix,
so I'm going to write out
the equations.
So it'll be minus U_(i-2)
plus 2*U_(i-1) minus U_i,
that would be F_(i-1); that
would be equation number i
minus 1, right?
With a minus 1, 2,
minus 1, centered there.
And then the next one will be
a minus U_(i-1) plus 2*U_i --
I better move this guy over
further -- minus U_(i+1),
that will be F_i, right?
That's equation number i,
and now I just want to look
at equation number
-- the next equation,
minus U_i plus 2*U_(i+1)
minus U_(i+2) is F_(i+1).
So I've written down three
consecutive equations,
three consecutive rows
from my simple matrix:
a row, the next row,
and the next row.
So the right-hand sides
are coming in order,
and the diagonals are there,
and if I look at that,
do I get any idea?
Well, there is an idea here.
I'd like to remove these
guys, the U_(i-1)'s and the
U_(i+1)'s, so that's where
this word odd-even reduction is
coming in.
I'm going to reduce
this system by keeping
only every second unknown
and eliminating those.
How to do that?
Well, you can see
how to eliminate.
If I multiply this
equation by 2.
If I multiply that
middle equation
by 2, that becomes a 4,
this becomes a minus 2,
this becomes a 2, and
now what shall I do?
Add.
If I add the equations
together, I get minus U_(i-2) --
these cancel, that was the
point -- plus 4 minus a couple,
so that's two u_i's,
minus this guy,
u_(i-2) is that sum F_(i-1),
two F_i's, and F_(i+1).
Well, sorry it's squeezed down
here, but this is the point.
The main point is look at this.
What do we have?
We've got a typical
equation, but now we've
removed half the unknowns.
The problem is now half-sized.
We've only got the
even-numbered unknowns
at a small cost in updating
the right-hand side,
and the problem's cut in half.
So that's this
odd-even reduction,
and it cuts a problem in
half, and everybody knows
right away what to do next.
The one mantra of computer
science, "Do it again."
So that is the same
problem on the even,
we do it again,
so I should really
call it cyclic reduction, we
just cycle with this reduction,
and in the end, we
have a 2 by 2 problem.
That seems pretty smart,
pretty successful move,
and I guess if we do
an operation count,
well, I haven't
thought that through.
What does the operation
count look like?
It must be pretty quick, right?
Well, undoubtedly we're
solving this linear system
in O of N steps.
Well, no big surprise to be able
to deal with that matrix in O
of N steps, because elimination
would take O of N steps,
it's size N, but it's bandwidth
is 1, so 2N or something steps
would do it, and
maybe, I don't know
how many steps we have here.
I guess, when we cut it
in half, that required
us to do that much.
It's order N, it's order N.
So the key question
is, can we do it 2D?
Can we do the same thing in 2D?
So I want to follow that
plan in two dimensions
where now U will be a
whole row at a time,
so I'm doing block 2D, block 2D.
So, can I write down the
equations in block 2D,
for whole rows?
So U_i is the vector -- So
now this is the 2D problem,
so it'll be minus
the identity --
where instead of instead of 1,
I have to write the identity --
U_(i-2) and 2K, right?
Oh no, what is the middle
-- what's on the --
so multiplying U_i, U_(i-1).
I wanted to just
say the same thing,
but I have to write down the --
this is going to be N squared
equations N at a time,
a whole row at a time,
and what's on the
diagonal of K2D?
Not 2K.
It's 2I, is it 2I plus K?
Yeah.
Yeah, K plus 2I.
Isn't that what we have on
the diagonal of the K2D one?
Times U_(i-1) minus
I*U_i is equal to some --
that's a whole row at a time.
These are all vectors with
N components now, right?
The minus i, the 2I, and
the minus I are the second
differences of one of
rows, they're difference is
in the vertical direction,
and this K*U_i the second
difference is along the row.
OK, so same equation
at the next row.
So the next row is minus
I*U_(i-1), K plus 2 U_i --
because that's now
the diagonal block --
minus I*U_(i+1) is F_(i+1).
And it'll just take me a
second to write this one.
This is K plus 2I U_(i+1),
minus I*U_(i+2) is F_(i+2).
OK.
Exactly the same, but now
a row at a time in 2D.
So the same idea is
going to work, right?
What do I do?
I want to cancel this, so I
multiply that row by K plus 2I.
Before I multiplied
it by 2, but now
I have to multiply
it by K plus 2I.
Times the row, the whole row.
So when I do that this
cancels, so I have minus this,
this guy wasn't affected.
And this will
cancel, the K plus 2I
will cancel this
one, just as before.
This will not be
affected, U_(i+2),
and I have F_i and K plus
2I F_(i+1) and F_(i+2).
That should have been i minus
1, and this should have been i,
and this should
have been i plus 1,
sorry, mis-labeled the
F's, but no big deal.
The point is the left
side, and the point
is what's in that space.
What goes in that space?
Well, it's minus I, K
plus 2I, squared, minus I,
so this is K plus 2I squared,
which before was so easy,
and then the minus I, and
the minus I is the minus 2I,
is multiplying the U_i.
Yeah, that was minus I.
OK, this is my matrix
from odd-even reduction.
It's just natural
to try the idea,
and the idea works,
but not so perfectly,
because previously in 1D, that
just gave us the answer 2;
it was 4 minus 2.
But now in 2D, we have a
matrix, not surprising,
but what we don't
like is the fact
that the bandwidth is
growing. k was tri-diagonal,
but when we square it, it
will have five diagonals,
and when we repeat the odd-even
cycles, when we do it again,
those five diagonals will be
nine diagonals, and onwards.
So, I'm getting
half-sized problems.
All the odd-numbered rows
in my square are eliminated,
this just involves the
even-numbered rows,
but the matrix is not
tri-diagonal anymore,
it's growing in bandwidth.
So, and then you have
to keep track of it,
so the final conclusion is that
this is a pretty good idea,
but it's not quite
as good as this one.
It's not as good as
the FFT-based idea.
Also, if you look to see
what is most efficient --
see the eigenvectors
are still here,
so I could do three steps of
this and then go to Fourier,
and that probably
is about right.
So, if you really wanted to
polish off a fast Poisson
solver, you could do
maybe two steps or three
of odd-even cyclic
reduction, but then
your matrix is getting messy and
you switch to the fast Poisson
solver.
So it's not quite
Poisson anymore,
because it's has
a messier matrix,
but it still has the
same eigenvectors.
As long as we stay
with the matrix K,
we know its eigenvectors, and
we know that they're sines
and that they're
quick to work with.
OK.
Anyway, there you go.
That's a fast algorithm for
the lecture before the spring
break.
So after the break is, first
of all, discussion of projects.
If your project could
include a page --
and you could maybe email
the whole project to Mr. Cho.
Maybe also, could you email
to me a sort of summary page
that tells me what you did, so
I'll save the summary pages,
and I'll have for Mr. Cho the
complete project with printout
and graph, as far
as appropriate,
and so we'll spend
some time on that,
and then move to the big topic
of the rest of the course,
which is solving optimization
problems, minimization,
maximization in many variables.
OK, so have a good spring
break and see you a week
from Wednesday.
Good.